this is Startalk we're back Startalk and
this is the how tweeted is part of the
show bill thanks for joining me thank
how sweet it is I probably need out top
to out tweet you here so I posted a
tweet not that long ago a couple of
months and just came upon these are like
brain droppings each day so but I know
you've thought about this so here it is
proud to be homo sapiens a curious
species with DNA compelling us to
explore even if doing so puts your own
life at risk
apparently why I believe I just wrote
about evolution what's your book
evolution the science of creation so if
you people who are ready to kill
themselves on Amazon or Barnes and Noble
anyway so ready to kill them so well the
word kill themselves they're willing to
take risks because taking risks well
when you take a risk there's a chance
you'll succeed at least when I take
risks you know it's interesting because
that's not how I think of risk I think
when you take a risk there's a chance of
you dying yeah well there's but there's
no that's a zero that's a fascinating
other way to think about it is a won
some game that which does not kill you
you presume would leave you alive and
the risk is taken to end with a chance
of enriching yourself and let me just
put it this way everybody you could
you're a woman you're female you could
go with the accountant there in the cave
in ancient cave days
aaaghh and I'll get back there or you
could take a chance on on the guy who's
a little wild who goes over the hill and
maybe we'll invent PayPal and just get
crazy rich and so if you put your cards
in with that guy put your lot in with
that guy there's a chance that you will
also succeed what are you saying about
accountants I'm saying the accountants a
steady guy but he may not strike it rich
so there's some value in the striking
rich scenario okay but if that were the
case there be no accountants oh no
because everybody's gotta passes gene
the guy who goes over they'll may get
killed there's lions and tigers and
bears
and parasites that be three different
continents actually all that aside that
I was trying to cover them all there are
penguins and I'd say you just added a
continent there's some there's some new
world monkeys that have trouble no oh
there's a bus in Australia everything's
venomous okay so but the guy that goes
over the hill gets the attracts the
female then the male that stays in the
cave doesn't reproduce is that right no
well it depends on what choice certain
females make I'm saying there's value in
the guy taking risk okay not that
accountants don't take risk but comedy
is based on stereotypes and so our
expectations which are based on
stereotypes so my feeling is that the
ancient cave accountants were more
conservative than the ancient cave over
the hill let's go forward Explorer okay
and so the over the hill let's go for it
explorers who never came back the
accountant had all the women okay that's
how the male accountant had all the way
okay that's why I became an engineer
okay it's a compromise you've been
listening to how tweet it is join the
conversation at star talk radio on
Twitter I'm the other grass Tyson bill
thanks always for being being on the
show thank you let's keep looking up as
always let's change the world this is
Startalk